ist eine idee die sie ist eine spitzen
idee perfekt zugeschnitten auf unsere
bedürfnisse das handy verfügt diva sage
und schreibe 0 klingeltöne diese super
bei einer märklin rudolf und jürgen
roters verstehst mit dem scheut oder
unten zb durch sagt johannes schäfer der
mit dem schickst du automatisch eine
nachricht ein dass der stammtisch haider
diesel inge bauer das ist oder links
oben drückte braucht dann magst du
automatisch den online kreuz für die csu
wenn es damals um 6 bis 8 uhr in deinem
leben schädel mit wurst und du mitten in
der nacht vom taxi stehst dann kann
diese funktion wirklich lebenswichtig
sein mein name ist france gruibinger ich
bin voll die 1000 russen bitte fahren
sie mich nach hause in die borkener
straße
23 bayern lb alles was der bayer braucht